Texas says it has no plans to comply
with the Biden administration's deadline
to turn over control of parts of the
border to federal agents and now 25
Governors are backing the state in the
standoff Florida attorney general Ashley
Moody joins us now AG Moody it feels
like our country is dividing into two
camps liberal states that for some
reason want to allow an invasion and
Republican states like Florida like
where you are that want to do everything
in their power to help Texas and fight
back against the Biden Administration so
what steps are you taking in Florida to
help Texas fight this
Invasion well you're right this is
becoming an untenable situation states
that have been in this long battle with
the federal government with our
president in the interest of protecting
Americans think about that you have a
president that is fighting against us
every step of the way to protect foreign
Nationals over his own citizens today
Florida will be in court battl battling
against them to keep them from releasing
in Mass they have mass release quotas
into the US Texas is battling as they
are putting up physical barriers and
every step of the way Biden has been
fighting them them in court forcing them
to take them down and so when New York
and Chicago and Massachusetts and all
these places are complaining because
they're overrun they're in a crisis
situation here it is right here today
Texas and Florida are fighting to keep
this country safe and secure and our
border strong and Biden has waged war
against us every step of the way well
Governor Abbott is also making a
constitutional argument he's saying that
if the federal government doesn't do the
job to protect the states then the
states have to do it for the federal
government it's called the right of
self-defense can you talk about
that absolutely and what governor Abbott
is saying look we can't be at the mercy
of a lawless president who refuses to do
his job and protect this country and
therefore because of this Invasion and
again he Biden allows records to be
broken every single month like we have
never seen before just last month
another record broken Texas can't take
it anymore and what governor Abbott is
saying look we have a right to defend
ourselves if our president won't do it
it's like having the police come to your
home and tie your hands and let your
home be overrun with people you don't
know people that are possibly there to
hurt you to hurt your home it is
untenable and states have been left with
the position of of standing strong not
just for their own citizens but for the
Safety and Security of this country it's
important also to cut through the legal
noise on this the Supreme Court of the
United States did not say Texas cannot
put up this wire it's simply allowed
based upon a procedural ruling uh the
federal government to take it down so we
can just go back on this back and forth
for as long as potentially possible we
will be watching it meantime want to get
your thoughts on this the Florida house
just approved a bill to ban social media
for kids under the age of 16 now heads
to the state senate it if it makes it to
D sanz's desk and he signs it the bill
would require platforms to prohibit
anyone younger than 16 regardless of
Parental approval require platforms to
use a thirdparty service for age
verification and call for platforms to
terminate accounts for users under 16
final thoughts to you AG Moody on the
importance of a bill like
this I think you're going to see leaders
all over the nation that are parents we
all have children folks are getting to
our children adults that want to do them
harm are getting to our children through
social media our children are being
exposed to inappropriate material
they're being addicted online uh we have
have to do something to stand up for our
kids I'm proud of the State of Florida
who is exploring ways to do that and I
think you're going to see that all over
the nation attorney general what would
you say to a parent who says I live in
the state of Florida so that I can make
the decisions for my own children I
don't want the government to get in our
way we have about 20 seconds remaining
for you to answer that
question look there are numerous
examples where we want to protect the
safety of our children especially from
those you know perpetrators batt actors
and I think Florida is trying to balance
the protection of parental rights uh
with the protection of our children and
we've always done a great job of that
we'll continue to do that all right
attorney general Ashley Moody thank you
so much for joining us on this Friday we
appreciate it I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley airheart and click
here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis